[Music]
you
hello friends and welcome back to
GameSpot today we have the pleasure of
bringing you Playstations latest psvr
title Farpoint which also comes in a
bundle with the new aim controller it's
pretty awesome
myself and my buddy Richie
Braca Mota who is over here on the PSV
our setup we're going to be playing some
today we're about 45 minutes into the
game at this point
and so Richie's gonna be playing with
the new end controller to kind of show
that off remember that because says this
is a PS VR game it's rendered at a lower
quality than what it seems to see inside
the VR headset so Richie are you are you
ready to go man ready man so ready your
initial impressions you think this games
pretty scary good but I wouldn't say
scary there are some pretty scary
enemies but I think it's terrifying not
you should be up here I know should not
be that's why I'm behind the desk are
dude let's uh let's get right into it
alright alright so to give everybody
kind of a background of where Richie is
and who he is at the beginning of the
game you are going to pick up these two
people up in a space station
their names are doctor moon and dr.
Tyson and so they're there now basically
you're studying this radiation cloud oh
we already have it up we have up we have
some takers you're studying a radiation
cloud and when you go to get into your
ship to head back to earth the cloud
explodes and you're sucked into a black
hole
so now Richie is playing as a pilot and
he's searching for these two other
doctors and he's on a hostile alien
planet we don't know what it's called
yet um what am I missing
Richie anything besides the aliens nope
you summed up the plot young you well
like now it's me looking for my friends
and aliens are
how would you describe these aliens
routine uh most of them are small like
this like they're they're annoying like
they're small and they burrow and they
jump at you so annoying is a pretty good
word and if you step on their blood you
get hurt a little bit so that's that's
also annoying but they get bigger and
they do get a little scarier like these
smaller creatures God Oh God
these smaller creatures are created from
these bigger creatures that look pretty
identical except they're like ten times
the size I'm not even playing the game
in this scares the bejesus out of me the
other day Nick I think I learned uh like
that you can smack the little burrow
dudes with your gun like this no I
knocked one out of the way and it was
hilarious
I might have [ __ ] been by accident
but well as everyone can see we're
pretty much playing against these little
crawling spider aliens and it's
terrifying you guys have any questions
though for richer myself about the
enemies the backstory cuz I'm not sure
if we covered it completely um this is
like as far as we know it's a lot a lot
of twists in this game a lot of twists
that we've been slowly uncovering so
we're still kinda in the dark it's fun
though like this is really immersive and
it's like a really good VR experience
overall I would watch your right side oh
look at that eye god where'd he go uh
what I'll say for anybody who's in the
comment section right now and asking
questions about the aim controller I
think we were both really impressed with
the way it kind of fit it's hard for it
to reflect what it looks like here in
the game it's so much better than it
looks like looking down the sights of
this gun feels as real as any gun has
been shooting the VR game before I don't
know if you feel the same way I do
taking like the goggles off is like kind
of funny because of how real it feels
in-game like the barrels longer and like
there are cool sights like this so I'm
really impressed overall with how this
handles like I don't really haven't have
any trouble with this
to this point yeah now Nick you want to
talk about like what these are I'm
looking at all right so since you guys
are looking for your to lost kind of
mates from the space station as you go
through the map that story kind of tells
itself through these holographic
messages and so we'll try to be quiet
during these parts these are basically
the little cutscenes they have yeah it's
like these are your friends and this was
recorded an earlier date
looks like you're about to pick up the
shotgun there it is waiting for me
so I played out like Star Wars you know
we had a couple questions already um
let's see a gunner
uh nope can you run and sprint in the
game yeah um yeah you can press down the
left stick it's not very um there we go
new shotgun um if you press down the
left stick you can run it's not super
fast but it's faster than walking
yeah I agree and it's it's tough to kind
of have this sprinting in games because
especially in VR games yeah cuz the
bouncing it might make people a little
bit motion sick so here's how this is a
kind of a healthy option yeah there's an
option to change weapons by slinging it
over your shoulder like that so there's
my machine gun and then there's my
shotgun again and reloading it's pretty
cool and I understand you can just hit
the square button switch no time for
that Nick Oh bring it on that's so gross
so gross
oh but yeah Nick to answer your question
you can switch weapons much faster just
by pressing I believe it's Y up here
here we go bingo and uh that comes in
handy like doing this it's pretty cool
but once I learned that you can do this
it's much easier yeah you're gonna need
to be quick
alright here we go so this is walking
and then this is like running so it is
smooth and I think it works for you know
not giving you a headache also this area
is pretty rough if I remember correctly
I don't know how you play this with such
composure I get don't look tight Nick
right now do I look tight right now you
look very relaxed I gotta extremely
stressed out especially in these cave
situations yeah when you don't know oh
say I hit with that few of those they
take you down quick so we should also
talk about the different types of
enemies so we'll have the small kind of
spider crawlers yeah they're the most
annoying as we mentioned before and they
they can burrow underground
and then jump on your face pop scare the
bejesus out of you then we have these
guys that you're fighting these are how
would you describe these um they're
bigger and more like annoying because
they throw those things at you like
they're okay when you have this gun yeah
it takes care of them no problem but
they also travel in groups so like
there's always more than one and you're
always getting flung like whatever that
mucus is on you and those like two or
three of those like mucus balls will
take you out yep so they're they're
difficult in that way um and then moving
on up we have the one that you just saw
when you picked up the shotgun those are
kind of the shielding spiders yes yeah
they make the little ones like if you if
you don't take those out right away
they'll shield themselves and then they
will make more of those little spiders
that are very annoying so try to take
those guys out if you can like right
away because they'll make more of these
and these are easy to deal with but they
also travel in like huge groups and they
can jump in your face yeah I think
there's a bouquet oh my god so we had a
couple questions Jamie Rhoads asked a
replaying on ps4 ps4 Pro we are playing
on the pro I really don't think that
makes a huge difference because it's
gspr but we are playing the pro and then
tripod killer asked if I would ever play
a horror game I actually Morse myself in
this office because of Ritchie to play
the entire campaign of res 7 and I think
it was my second favorite game of the
year so and he did it all at work it was
great watching him like yell at his
table just profanity over and over so
hey I got grenade a grenade launcher
with grenades I can see right here I now
have some grenade ammo to take care of
what's in front of me and now the
grenade launcher is only compatible with
the shotgun correct there's a rocket
launcher on the assault rifle you just
need bullets for either of them and
there are little scarce around here I
think I might have left you some rocket
launcher uh
ammo oh great least I tried I think I
did seize him
alright so he's
there you go oh you know how these are
not obviously unlimited but so that's
the that's the shield oh my good god up
and that's what it looks like when you
die so close but in what we needed that
when you needed that yeah let's see
those else for you put it looks like one
of those things gets right in your face
all right take two here we go
so there's one of the more difficult
areas right uh it was yeah it took me a
few time to get past this because
there's a bunch of little dudes and a
bigger dude oh oh my guns keep
overheating so I just tried to take them
out as quick as I could with these these
are very helpful but you have to know
they're like trajectory otherwise yeah
you'll miss oh here one and for those of
you who haven't noticed uh both the
shotgun and a salt rifle ah they got me
again reloading up a chump ripping this
yeah I feel like I feel like you got
this I got it yeah so if for those of
you didn't notice the shotgun and the
assault rifle the the assault rifle
overheats so you don't have to reload
that one but it's unlimited ammo and the
shotgun is the same where it's unlimited
ammo but you hold the square button to
recharge the square button let's see
yeah I believe it is square okay there's
definitely a healthy amount of and
Nishan yes coming after you dude not
again very guys
now's little beans these little dudes
horrible drawer come on
and so this is the shield guy oh nice
there we go I like to do this when
you're done nice cuz you can yeah you
can blow you know you enver huh both do
that
I'm afraid that they'll come back gum I
swear I might have seen it once and I
freaked out how great all right these
are the little mucus puss throwing nasty
ones now those explode to see can't get
too close
yeah I try to use this all watch out
though
overheating okay don't have anymore yes
I do so I've seen a lot of comments in
the chat about the height for the ain't
controller I do understand a lot of
people's kind of hesitation with the
fact that the PSV are so expensive but I
really think that the de Paris is one of
the most legit accessories oh uh I tried
oh yeah he did now they just backed up
me and also do those things move around
is so okay I'm reloaded so here's
another memory like log that I can uh
just uh so you're gonna use your scanner
yeah it's above the trigger you just use
a scanner to unlock this there's my
friend let's see what is she what is she
found basically you're in you're kind of
following her footsteps trying to find
her yeah they definitely came through
here I see a question from marked he was
asking is this a standing or seated
experience that's a good question I
think if you set your camera keeps it if
you wanted to what yeah yeah I think you
could sit we've primarily been playing
standing up yeah um just because I think
it's easier to maneuver yourself around
but it's definitely not necessary yeah I
also feel like it helps so with the
immersiveness like I'm like you know
staying just like this guys oh I hear
something
another one alright another question say
it was this metal god can I turn off the
bobbing in the settings um I don't
believe so I'm Amish
or it's just turned down for when you
strip
see I don't like this standing here Oh
cuz that a new one - or is that still
these are just the same enemies we've
seen so far
um I know very soon we're gonna see some
new where I'm see a couple new aliens
some bigger badder aliens for sure yeah
so this is a sprint speed and uh like
it's alright I was gonna mention the the
other thumbstick helps you turn you know
instead of your head you can also just
use a thumb stick like this it's a
little doing both kind of hurts your
head if you know you're not in total
control yeah but there's a you know it
took me a few tries but I'm comfortable
and my head isn't her right now which is
very fortunate darkbeat wants to know is
the controller's support any other psvr
games I'm not quite sure uh I think this
might be whoa this might be the first
game it's compatible with I bet you down
the line it will be compatible this is
like the gun maybe I'm not sure know if
it's compatible with any of the older
games because I know there are a couple
shooters that were on um kind of the
psvr yeah we use the obvious the move
instead of this thing yeah I think
having those with the two controllers
having like two guns into a wildung I
don't think this would work because that
would be only one controller only one
gun let's get out of here huh yeah
please get out of the cave it's horrible
and just for anyone that has any
questions I am in the youtube and the
twitch chat oh so if you have any
questions for Ritchie you have any
special requests you want him then try
something yeah shout it out cuz uh this
is a lot of the same with the shooting
the aliens but like if you want me to
look around more just let me know Nick
this area is pretty tough took me
a handful of tries here oh look miss
that one that's alright for show
am i good now can you hear me excelente
thank you Richard sorry anyone who
couldn't hear me as I blabbed on
I see a couple people saying that it
looks pretty good I will tell you I
think it looks really good on the screen
itself but I think it looks even better
in VR I mean obviously it's shed some
defining VR stuff right here like I'm
totally into this but like I'm getting
my ass handed to me oh nice
using those Rockets I saved up yep kind
of phew
these little guys are so annoying I
would argue that the smaller the aliens
are in this game this scary they are I
mean you can't see them sometimes
they're like oh yeah whoops
you can't see them so that that's a part
of the scary factor like the kind of
burrow and they jump and they blend in
with the background so I agree with you
for that reason they are sages they look
like you know when you see like a spider
crawl up the wall like yeah well get
ready cuz there's a big spider coming up
there's some music playing and I'm
pretty sure this is this is it oh my god
they're all like converging somewhere no
they're coming at me okay
this is what is there are a lot I know
I'm surrounded that must mean oh shoot
you gotta reload straight straight
Nathaniel in the YouTube chat made a
good comment I believe there is a reddit
channel that'll kind of keep you updated
on what is compatible Oh with a aim
controller very cool yeah I'd love to
see this thing use more and like
wherever it can be used so uh that's
good news ah alright I feel like this is
like gladiator style right look at this
arena again like I'm surrounded all
right
oh there was some Emma over here protip
oh nice
Oh for both guns ah as you guys noticed
there's some debris here on the map that
debris is from the space station as it
comes crashing down onto this unknown
you know alien planet
the debris is kind of like strewn all
around the planet and so basically you
and the other two scientists are trapped
on here
you're basically kind of backtracking
trying to find the other survivors
they're all got some company Nick
oh my god there's where the little ones
are coming from no I need to take care
of the guide now uh somebody was asking
how is the difficulty look looks like
hand in glove on twitch was asking how
is the overall difficulty oh well
that might tell you right there it gets
a little it gets a little tough like it
starts you off smooth from you know what
I played so far and then it really kind
of throws you into it either that or I
gotta get good cuz I keep dying but um
no my first playthrough through this
area did take me a while too so I mean
the difficulty spikes for better or
worse I'm having fun though like it
makes you want to keep trying it doesn't
feel like it's your fault would you say
it's more kind of like not wave-based in
the sense that you're kind of going
through this map on this like linear
path and as you get to each kind of boss
battle this is one of the like mini boss
battles before you get some bigger stuff
um it does feel sort of wave basis in
situations like this like I do you know
just walk into a room and then like I'm
surrounded like out of yellow so that's
a pretty good way to put it but like
there's more narrative to kind of
balance that out yeah I'm just gonna try
to get over here there's way too many of
those little dudes
chiva our Twitter expert says go Richie
go just sending you encourage Thank You
Sheila
oh alright alright see ok well health
does regenerate like on your own like
I've noticed but like I I'm getting
pummeled this is uh well miss a in the
YouTube says the tiny ones are really
annoying because they scatter everywhere
yeah great
I don't like focus on the big ones when
those things are like coming from all
sides all angles yeah I think you guys
are trying to I think you guys see what
I'm trying to do I am trying to like
kind of handle these little guys but
they're only gonna keep coming if I
okay the big guys yeah so like there's
one behind them but I'm trying to get to
them my guns overheating a lot of things
are going on here
nice nice get rekt
imma get rekt reload reload and again we
are playing on a ps4 Pro but I I really
don't think that that makes a gigantic
difference because we're playing on the
VR okay here we go all right the big gun
the big one I really like the big one
can block kind of the grenade shots and
stuff like that with those big shields
possibly I mean it I think I feel Diesel
sprinting oh great there we go
oh we got him nice I thought it was
cornered there for a sec I couldn't back
up anymore when he's like sprinting at
you he's really really vulnerable to
your shotgun yeah the shotgun also has
really good range like surprisingly good
range how are you casually walking
around those just try and get away from
them and this is this is me running
watch that's happy that's just how it is
I'm glad it doesn't bounce like I'm
actually running that would just make me
puke so I'm hearing some violin some
very dramatic
huh it's not over yet alright next one I
see Miss Maggie Nick and Aaron are you
oh you can't do it okay something is
that was loud this is like gladiator
zone look at this I'm not a reload or
anything oh they're so comfy just keep
coming yeah this is oh my god don't get
so close dude you're crazy I'm just
trying to progress I'm trying to get the
hell out of oh boy
Nathaniel in YouTube says the coop is a
blast in Farpoint as well we haven't
done a co-op we have good [ __ ] yeah
Ritchie can do all the work and all
power in fear in the corner our next
time I'll commentate and Nick you're not
here yet this would have to be a rated-r
stream you said that
I don't like you dude okay I need to
progress I'm gonna try going over they
just keep coming man this is insane Oh
big one big one and I'm out of rockets
oh not Rockettes grenade lock grenades
they hurt each other when they explode
near each other I don't know if you knew
that Nick they like I've seen others day
are you deaf no he's not down okay Oh
God
Oh God thank you God there are more pubs
around it this is me running people and
those are your slow clothes and those
are your pupils on the side like that
red right in here you are it's just like
you know it's it's it's my pupils
they're only looks like you oh no wow
they backed me up to here okay I don't I
know that there's ammo here I'm gonna
try to come back to this before it's too
late
I don't think they did push you back all
the way I think they're pushing you to
where the two sides come in
let's hope cuz there would be yeah there
would be a bunch of the mimic looking
one you're right there's less of them
let's hope okay more mimics behind me
that's that's actually put a pretty good
description
vivix yeah they look like mimics but
like 1000 times worse huh
do I just need it I think I just need to
clear the room like to progress I can't
seem to find a way out of here like
there are these little areas over here
that oh my god yeah okay up watch out
when you do the whole tailspin yeah
that's when it comes charging me okay
I'm not a professional tripod killer
asked if I would play to play prey and
the answer is yes I think prey is
awesome
I want to try praying vo hard would be
horrible though that's a good question
that's a good situation is that if that
guy's dead I just totally wasted a Roger
okay
I think there are more rockets and stuff
back right where you started to so you
probably go grab those excuse me coming
through
reloading okay here we go that's what we
have so yeah are we taking twitch at
somebody was asking how the controls
feel i honestly after playing oh one of
the big ones alive after playing this
game for like an hour I thought that
this was the best kind of like aiming
combat whoa all up in my face combat
shooting with like a controller for VR
it's very like fluid very like very easy
to pick up and play I played this and I
was hooked and I wanted to keep going so
like if that doesn't tell you something
also I want to highlight me something
everyone appreciates as much as they
should this is insane Ricky's talking
and plane which is one of the most
difficult things ever Nick you can
barely play yeah unda why embarrass
gonna walk you though okay something
this is what happened last time there's
a shadow up there and I got to get out
of here so so it's big right something
okay
looks like part of the ship is starting
to collapse oh good look nice hopefully
without interruption looks like my
friends have been here before
it's a big chunk of the pilgrim there it
is and anytime they refer to pilgrim
pilgrim is the giant Space Station that
came crashing down onto this planet
through a radiation black hole there it
goes
so pilgrim is not a person it's a space
station right at first we thought the
pilgrim was referring to me which is
incorrect all right so we got a little
cutscene here so yeah we'll let you
enjoy you might want to turn up the
volume in the back too because these
cutscenes are very quiet I got a theory
so there's a dr. moon skimmed here like
a stone that would put the final crash
side another about maybe 15 16 klicks
away I'll crunch the numbers can you
stretch your rations back boy
yeah
I purged the Hat by the way pressures
holding
even this and we are comfortable is
pretty cool cuz like I'm right here okay
people I'm very close to this dude we're
not staying
this will hear back from them later we
had a question how does the rumble feel
on the aim controller from Kratos
forever that's good
I'm just now realizing that it does feel
good like you are shooting and it
vibrates just enough it's not over it's
not overbearing but it's subtle lady
Bart but it works
yeah these cutscenes are all yeah if
you'd like I can skip some but some of
these I remember this one is actually a
little longer beautiful yeah yeah nice
amen let me see little torture you know
I have to make the signal right I'm good
character building I only know the
lyrics of elementary songs Oh BJ well
that shots fired because I happen to
love della victory no you do I do
no one loves della Beatrice so one of
these click to chat like he was kind of
like talking because she mentioned how
she's bored so he's like I might have to
sing for you she's like I love deli meat
reso singing some deli meetry it's Palin
around
interesting you know lonely out here
it's actually just I feel like they're
giving us some like background into
there yeah just some more character
buildings an audience oh he told me to
look up at this guy look at that told
her to look up Wow history the universe
is that crazy
pretty crazy to their knowledge this
planet is like an undiscovered territory
side in and it's pretty big news that
they're here yeah I think that they said
at the beginning one of the first
cutscenes when you first arrived there
they asked where are we and it's no
known location yeah
the the intro yeah where they get like
crash-landed on this plane and so you
don't know where they are really yeah we
should be fine right now he dr. moon
who's the gentleman right there in the
front he is just he's back in one of the
parts of the space station they found ya
and then dr. Tyson is out exploring
trying to find more parts to the overall
Space Station yeah and like find me I
think like are you are looking for them
okay you are we're not really sure what
your character's name is they that you
play as the protagonist mmm-hmm but what
we do know is that you were the pilot
for the ship that was supposed to take
those two back to earth that's right
that's how the game starts he I was
their pilot supposed to pick them up so
there's a little station here we get
some in from information here that's
pretty important yeah
scoot up
so that means there are other people
imagine wait see if they come back for
those of you who are asking about the
review for Farpoint I believe it's going
up this afternoon don't hold me to it
but be on the lookout for the written
review and some more gameplay definitely
soon I don't think I kind of like doing
this just a little bit not and like I
feel like that takes so much time and
for anyone else asking how far in we are
in the game when we started we were
about 45 minutes in and so now we're
another half hour or so yeah so maybe
max with the cutscenes and everything
we're like an hour half in the game is
about a five to six hour long campaign
so it's a pretty significantly girthy
long it's like it's a little shorter
than Resident Evil but the pacing and
this is really good so far so like it's
it's all fine like I have no complaints
with like the story and like the amount
of action and yeah so like you get lost
in it so it doesn't really matter
it might be I hear Richard laughing so
that means that he heard the way I
described the campaign as a girthy and I
try to do you see try I try to take it
from there but uh how big was it oh this
house skipping it's can't wait here we
go as big as this fun this returning by
your food yeah I know I'm turning red oh
oh here Nick look at the screen
get your color back yeah it's gonna be
more red because I'm scared here oh and
this
we got redder you're not more red you
know your gang they're ganging up on me
just like these guys you know I think I
think Nick you have it worse right now
than I do
it's dude here killing it so there we go
I gotta take care of these our viewers
even hear the voice of God don't need to
there you know hey you know what
comet ears are very nice today I love it
only one person made fun it was probably
a GameSpot scary no it was not come on
there we go
dude you're killing it now I'm trying I
got to reload this thing get away watch
pull I think some people are saying that
it's it's the review is up oh great so
go check that out you sure - thinking's
going up around 2 p.m. today so when we
started perfect there we go okay alright
music died down now I think I've cleared
the area nope
are you dry again Nick ready smack oh no
I'm with you it has worked but where you
going you yeah here he goes all right
back into another cave here we go
load it up I like this cuz uh it's got
good range the shotgun or the the
assault rifle okay and like you just
have to worry about um overheating the
barrel cuz it's unlimited ammo that's
great in this gun I feel like the for
the big ones that kinda have shields on
the front of the missile shells this is
the way to go with those things I feel
like the assault rifle doesn't really
damage yeah it's it's weaker yeah
alright these are like this cavern is
really nice like especially in VR I'd
like to comment it looks weird on the
screen - oh no are you gonna fall uh
I'm thanks no not if I can help it
don't fall oh wow last time Nick early
remember the whole the whole thing like
this whole structure like caved in hey
what's up the whole it caved in on me
and I fell down on the ground member
that earlier
I really thought something was gonna pop
out from underneath the walkway right
there and like you're now kind of going
into territory that I this is pretty
trailer here this is pretty much where I
was like you know what I'm good
i-i've seen as much as I want to I'm
here then you know flashlight would be
pretty tight right now but look at
there's the end right there
we're okay Nick cool
maybe mo know anybody that was asking
about bosses we're gonna try 200 new
enemy man check it out ah gross I don't
want to show you what he doesn't for
fear of getting hurt but it's like the
little spiders only gigantic yeah and
when they get close to you they spit
acid on you and it takes you out in like
one spin so you try to just make short
work of this God have a tough two that's
a three blast
NAR ste nars D fresh and he is burrow -
yeah that's right he burrowed like right
towards me oh boy whoa there's one
there's one peeking I'm gonna slide over
here so now we have the small spider
ones we have the ones that kind of shoot
the balls of acid yeah we have the big
shield one and we have now these large
burrowing ones that can spit acid at you
yeah and they do nope no chances no no
chances cool like this like can they
surprise you um no they usually burrow
from like within like eyesight like what
we just saw
that's about they don't gonna pop up any
more than that huh I'm in this K we'll
keep this handy look nathaniel says he
doesn't see the far point interview on
gamespot.com yet so keep your eyes
peeled I'm not sure what time exactly
should go up today though for
sure so Nick did you stop around here
did you ever meet the ice tiger dude
okay no I I I said no thanks huh hard
pass okay my god surrounded here see
spitting up on me I got a backup why
don't you just take a break everyone
okay
oh I can't just unload my shotgun on
this guy cuz there's like a an animation
where like he doesn't take damage so I
got a I'm out oh my god I thought you
killed the one and then there was a
second one like right behind it
oh yeah there was there was at least two
and I'm hearing more this is Oh are you
going oh I still think my least favorite
that's where the little ones Oh Oh see
that's why yeah that one like crept
right up to me okay here we go
overheating nope he's pushing the other
one look he oh oh God
Nick I really wish you were behind the
VR goggles right yeah dude I'm I have
anxiety and I'm watching you on a screed
yeah that's okay it's fun to watch you
play though next time we'll get you
behind here yeah you're just there too
many risks you know you know everybody
already saw I can't really talk you know
about this game without saying something
in the wrong way just for the game so
you don't want to know what I would say
if something if one of those things
popped out of the ground and scared me
I'll tell you I'll tell you something
right now it'd be a lot worse than the
word girthy yeah you can't get to the
sensor button fast enough yeah bleep
yeah oh this part I do remember because
like I kept looking over the edge like
this and it's pretty cool there's a
there should be an interaction coming up
here soon
ooh whoa for better or worse Nick all
right let me get behind actually I'll go
in front of her right here and uh yeah
sure you want to uh there we go there we
go okay I reckon scan yeah same look at
that yeah it's like neat yeah all right
I'm on cool yeah that's cool this is fun
okay get away from me yeah I'm gonna
whoopsie-daisy which
this is also cool because in the
settings you can tell the game how tall
you are and the game will respond core
like it'll correspond with everyone
else's height um so sometimes you'll
look over people and then sometimes
you'll look up at them yeah here we go
what are you doing here Oh No why are
they on this they're here man they're
everywhere they run this planet we're
the aliens you see that I think one of
the things it's Oh God another one one
of the things that's interesting is that
when you see these cutscenes it doesn't
really seem like these the two
astronauts that you're looking for I
don't think that Dave's whoa I feel like
they haven't seen these enemies right
they don't feel uh like they're not
coming off as scared or like yeah they
haven't reported anything like something
you know we have some one unanswered
question that one yeah I like that one
hold on you have some unanswered
questions for sure and I can't wait to
play the rest of this
I will say I know that they oh my god
this is where I learned to smack them
with my gun my mistake is I was like gah
in real life
oh and it worked I smacked one against
this cliffside actually okay what we're
good
oh that was so gross okay couple people
in the comments are making a comparison
to dead space I just say this is this
reminds you yeah it's kind of the same
like like you have a small group of
friends and not friends well comrades
are like crash land on a strain at a
strange place and the way you recover
information is pretty similar right and
I love dead space can I pick here we go
it's gotta get close to it you guys ever
play the dead space like a game on the
Wii right oh it's right it was actually
pretty good
dead dead space for those of you I'm not
sure we get here John Luke is chirping
our ear about the dead space we game
what was it called
oh man had a extraction there is
traction I did not play like it was one
of those things where I couldn't justify
the purchase but now I'm hearing it's
pretty good would you consider yourself
a big a big dead space fan Ritchie yeah
well uh pretty much like I haven't
played every last installment but one
two and three one and two especially are
like gold okay oh that cool a boo is jaw
you know I don't like him here there you
go I feel like I've been neglecting the
twitch chat I'm sorry
the moan had asked earlier how does the
VR headset feel on your head
oh the psvr is probably my favorite it's
very comfortable and it works well with
people with glasses I have some pretty
big framed glasses and I'm very
comfortable it's overall this is like
really it's also very lightweight so I
can't say enough good things about that
either
I know from I don't I don't wear glasses
but I think it's really comfortable
um come on I know I feel like the old
boy glasses are a bit of an issue when
it comes with like the oculus and the
vibe yeah I've tried the two of them ah
that was crazy they're sort of
surrounding me here
the psvr it's just it's very it fits
comfortably on your head yes um it's
very adjustable and uh yeah overall
comfortable on my head I would like to
say that I like to play with the lights
off um when we do play just so that the
little bit of light can get in
underneath underneath your eyes but
other than that it's pretty fantastic I
agree like I'm having no trouble whoa
keep dying but I mean no trouble with uh
any of the anything the psvr has to
offer so ah you're doing great I guess
that one guy that was pretty difficult
he's okay oh God surprise
he's barfing up on me I might not make
it
oh okay that older ones this game does
really well it distracts you and makes
you look up and then something adjusts
up down wow it really does I've been
killed like twice like that already okay
here we go let's try that again this is
it is a very linear experience in the
sense that you're you're kind of on a
track and on a trail and as you go down
you know you encountered I guess pods
and waves of enemies of aliens I would
say it is very linear though you can't
like wander off yeah
very far there are seen alternate paths
but they're very short and it's like
they lead you to the same place yeah
yeah I don't like I'm gonna try to take
them out from here oh great he's sending
little dudes
I kill I keep forgetting that she can
make them right he's oh I got a booklet
I was gonna say he's a hotshot girl even
the little ones Oh like did you have
anything left for him he's about to be
right in your face all right let's just
breeze through let's do it again will
thank you next time Nick part two like
the sequel to this movie
ah doc leisure wants to know do you
think this game is a is a it's a good
enough reason to make the purchase for a
psvr I've been on the fence about that
very same question
um I mean with this packaged in like if
you get the bundle with this and I'm not
sure if there's a PSP our bundle with
this but I'm teetering on that same
question and I I need to play a little
more but I'm definitely enjoying myself
yeah um I know the game and it comes
with the bundle is $70 retail I think so
a maybe seventy nine ninety nine I
believe or 69 somewhere in that area so
you get the game and you get the amp
controller which is rad ah but I know I
know a lot of people that it's a tough
decision because the psvr is rather
expensive yeah it's a tough decision you
you know and I played it Oh smack around
I need bullets who I don't like I don't
like what he's doing over there oh he's
coming for you dude bring it on any
little friends oh he coming he did blew
his jaw off again is that one dead I
think it's great that I hate that I hate
that see you're right like this game
sort of distracting just cuz it's like
VR and then like you get pummeled like
that okay these these barf bags gotta go
one of the one of the good things that I
found is that when those enemies jump at
you like that yeah they'll automatically
kind of like go behind your back and
then swoop back into like your range of
fire that's very true
yeah cuz it would be
very jarring for like the somebody who
might get motion sickness easily uh
having to like quickly turn around and
look exactly because you can but like
you might knock a lamp over look
something like that
instead they also give you that second
analog stick to move like I mentioned
before and that's a perfect segue Marcus
Jones once and it wants to know how is
the motion sickness with the game um I
don't know that I get motion sickness
personally and this is a good way to
test that I think cuz right now I feel
like I'm in complete control and you
only get that motion sickness when
you're not in total control so once you
get the controls down and yeah
everything is very fluid I think you'll
be fine and that's coming from someone
who gets carsick very easily me uh
I get um I guess seasick not really the
same real easily similar yeah but I
guess not the same you've but with this
game the only time I started to feel
like kind of ill was when I turned on
the turning so you use the your left
hand to kind of control your front
motion back motion strafing that in my
holistic yeah in the back stick but for
your right hand oh god there's two I
know that stick I was using feel kind of
like turn myself instead of letting the
the gun aim it and that made me a little
sick because the turning was so it was
so jarring they can't be there are good
settings to fix that and the settings
you can you can have complete control
okay hold on yeah we'll talk in a sec
now you have complete control in the
settings of whether or not you want like
oh he's running at you there we go the
little ones the little ones God alright
Stan how you're like haha like wow Oh a
lot of things coming at - you look so
real you gotta try to get into yarn egg
never never okay I got a reload um
the control is top-notch like I'm
I can't say enough good things about the
control and like I'm not getting sick I
hope that I get some questions and I I
don't think it's the controller so much
that makes me feel sick it's just like
the too quick like turning from side to
side too quick yeah the second analog
stick guides me because like I mentioned
I can turn like this if I want but if I
don't want to do this and snap my neck
at lightning speed yeah I can use the
other analog stick instead or alongside
with I'll apologize a lot of people are
asking questions about coop oh I'd love
to try we got so into kind of playing
ourselves that we totally forgot to
explore the coop
yeah options 100% honest I didn't know
it was a co-op compatible game totally
forgot so we should problem that he's
awesome yeah get into that cuz I would
be a lot less you have that buddy yeah
I'd be a lot less freaked out oh there
are like some alien pods here dude mmm
yeah that's a clean house here a little
bit mm-hmm gross no I don't think that's
gonna do much I'm surrounded with these
so okay
no I have a question for you have you
have you personally gone this far in the
campaign this is actually where I
stopped yesterday oh boy I had to get
back to uh making those dank memes for
those of you who don't know Richie's
which is his dank Twitter handle
he works on our social team and so any
of all funny hilarious mean content that
you follow anniversary's I love and
anniversaries are Richie over here
straight killing it Thank You Nick most
Nick's Nick was okay there are bones
here I know where you are
Nick was once on our social media team
as well
I am tiles are
uh-oh Nikki scared me this looks like
another arena so let's see what's up I'm
excited to see you saved this for me
honey your reaction this is uh we've
gotten to kind of a a turning point in
this stream right now I wasn't sure we
were gonna make it this far and we have
how much time do we have
will I be able to take on what's going
on here hopefully you'll be able to uh
at least I'll be able to see I'm pumped
I'm not gonna ruin it
okay let's not ruin it for our audience
either this reticle I don't know we
haven't talked about much is like so
cool cuz you can line it up it becomes
like a full-blown red dot reticle when
you align it with your face like if you
play with it like this it won't work and
your aim is off but you really have to
line it up so I might need to do that
cuz something is gonna happen here for
sure so I feel so small right now I have
a question for you Richie when you aim
down the sights of the gun yeah I do you
close an eye yes I close my left eye
like I'm really - that's I think that's
great for me is what makes the aim
controller so cool oh boy
and I don't even know I was doing it you
asked me and I was like oh yeah I am
totally actually okay there gonna be a
lot of ammo let's listen okay I've never
felt this small in this game yeah I am
feeling you can I just start let's go in
your face
all right he's like Chaffin oh there's
his core there you go weak spot let's go
oh no oh okay so he sends shockwaves at
me oh boy so he can send shock shock
waves at you and he can also spawn
everything are you kidding me yes every
okay I gotta move move move so get get
pumped I apologize in advance because
I'm gonna be jerking around
using my own controls and uh I want to
make anyone sick but you would - this is
this is too much
this guy's not even attacking me with
like all his force I know it he's just
he's playing games right now
come on it looked big from here on the
screen and what everyone is seen
described how you're feeling right now
you feel some all the first thing I said
man I'm gonna stick with it I feel puny
I'm looking up at this thing this is
crazy yo all right come on oh three do
you feel miss a wants to know in the
YouTube chat are you scared
uh Loki scared this is pretty scary the
other things were like fun and like
exciting I don't know what's gonna
happen here do I hit him now going on
load up oh my I'm not even moving out of
his cave he's not he's playing with me
you see Nick how I don't know if you've
been looking at me at all but I'm like
moving like the like it's happening oh
no boy he's moving he's like he's like
I'll let you deal with this oh come on
all right
you got some little ones so now we kind
of have a little bit of a wave base oh
no and he's gonna be firing some stuff
out you know I don't uh oh geez
go away I don't need those little guys
right now this is awful
look like ah so yeah yeah this is like
everything I've trained for come on
hmm Nick I'm starting to feel like you
right now man ah that's right oh I was
gonna let you go with it your reactions
are hilarious oh boy yeah I bet my I
would focus on I need this guy out of
the picture I would focus on the stuff
down low [ __ ]
oh he coming for you what was look at
that all right time to take care of some
business up here oh I can't oh oh boy I
notice not using these huh his it looks
like his kind of acid that he's spitting
at you or a different color yeah they're
like oh wait I'm under it
don't know no one burro who I need eyes
on everyone right now okay
okay their supply meet with enough stuff
I'm gonna give it another shot here come
on
oh great his mouth has to be wide open
come on come on oh my god okay I'm
getting pummeled again this is not cool
I'm trying to focus on one thing and I
am surrounded like I am yo that's the
best thing this this game does it gets
you to focus on Oh Oh get away it gets
you to focus on things and while you're
locked in look at me I'm locked down
like this I'm like freaking out yeah
when you're locked in you forget that
all this other scary stuff is going on
around you it's awesome though it's like
the scariest like realest thing okay all
right now that I know what I'm up
against
here's hoping I do better I'm gonna try
to get the Rockets in this guy's face
come on people are saying that there's
no tension in this boss fight I think
it's just because you're pretty good at
this game rich yelling outs what's going
on rosetta is that a compliment cause I
think they try to keep my cool but I'm
like the jab but it's also I got the low
key jab yeah
oh boy okay my character just said oh my
god all right say
fire bucket in the chat he wants you to
hug the spider here I come mmm whoa you
are so close now it's for you come on
come on yes that's all good I got him
I need to know where I'm backing up into
I keep backing into things like cuz
that's just part of the game and it's
it's cool but like a little too real
come on come on come on oh oh okay those
do low damage that's okay come on
oh no you go there we go can I hit him
now no I'm not gonna waste my boards
come on oh now he's gonna leave me to
the little guys and I know that
experience so he it's okay to die
sometimes he's game whoa Oh I won't lie
when those little spiders jump at me I
close my eyes oh I can't I have to see
where they're at
I clown I screwed that up wait long you
mentally I think you got overly
confident in that maybe yeah I was
getting a little close but I just wanted
to nip that in the bud man that guy
needs to go okay here we go
all right I feel like you got this yeah
how's the comments doing uh people are
giving you some suggestions let's hear
him Doug good just behind things oh yeah
that helped me last time everyone was
doing this you could get behind some
stuff and Weezy bidding yes okay Thank
You Chad keep coming
what else any other suggestions you guys
want to share
yeah with Richie as he fights the giant
spider from oh come on I need a trigger
the event here I go ooh
see you're closing yet I know I want him
to hurry oh this sucks oh good good okay
yeah I'm gonna hide behind here as
suggested same
come on Omar God first time he says yeah
the first time he does that can't hurt
him look it's not lit up so I'm not
gonna waste my boy here we go
what do you think he's saying ah that's
a direct translation yeah well now he's
toying with you yeah you're just looking
at me you have eyes oh here we go ah
missed this is an awesome tip already
I'm ready I feel safe already so I think
you guys are are noticing too and
Ritchie fires the rocket from the
assault rifle you guide the rocket with
the reticle yes this one you just
launched but the other one is guided by
your controller yep
overheating okay getting a lot of lot of
demands they want to play co-op sorry we
are not set up that's a good idea but
call some other nation but maybe one day
here we go alright okay not cool
alright sue might want to get some cover
because he's gonna send a ton of other
minions at you
good plan here we go
oh don't forget keep keep your eyes
peeled down low yeah cuz you've got
better cover amongst the little dudes oh
my god yeah that's what I'm sayin see
you were focused on him and lo Oh God
yep here they come
okay I got a coupon right Oh weird there
they are
what Wow whoo oh god I'm out I'm out
about cool hit him oh I didn't do then
okay now I'm being here we go here we go
here we go yes very nice we load this
them that assault rifle has quite the
range yeah it's pretty ridiculous but I
need it right now
I need that range well I'm gonna assume
with all these little ones that there's
got to be one of them yeah they're
probably another one that's coming out
of the cave here I would be so scared to
look around that corner Oh what was that
one doing I was like on my side okay
here we go
load up switch over yes Oh that little
guy got in the way there we go good good
it I need more rockets Oh
Oh
here we go there they are - yes -
remember just one oh two of them I wish
I wish I can like Oh God speak clearly
this is a lot going on right now just
watch watch out you have another one of
those oh boy
Oh God
I need more rockets cuz these things
don't launch very far no okay that
wasn't that uh well there you go you got
some rockets I've missed my shot watch
out though cuz he's getting close to you
he is moving forward I backed myself
into this little cave again here we go
oh my god did you get that one uh
exponent gets a lot I've only angered it
alright Nick what's where people say in
the comments Manny's a milk uh-oh
how about reload Richie oh my god some
people were asking questions about how
this is co-op if it's easier enough dad
that's a great question we can't really
answer it I could use some help right
now
I know that yeah ok I need to find more
Rockets and I think there's more where I
started
Oh God jeez
okay hmm
see here you almost got him hopefully uh
I hate when oh okay I think they're
scurrying do I have a fighting chance
here Nick wait a minute oh oh he's he's
like looking at me like hmm okay this
guy's a little tougher than I thought I
think he's he's also extremely mad dude
oh we gotta go huh is he coming down oh
did I do it oh yeah all right thank you
chat I'd like to thank chat Nick
margarita holding it down Ida Matlin
Richie's all you know co2 blood here hmm
oh my goodness I've uncaptured another
memory or something like that here we go
I guess we'll enjoy this cutscene and
then I think we'll bring this this
beautiful stream to an end we'll call it
a day I think that's a fitting end let's
see what we learn here yeah I think we
learned something pretty significant in
this cutscene Nick am I facing like the
opposite way now like yesterday I was
playing I finished and I was like this
nope you're good let's get crazy outside
look at our casually walking out of this
see that's know what I had to go through
yeah so it makes me think they haven't
seen the enemies yet yeah
so he's dr. moon has made a discovery is
basically what what he's she is out in
the field looking for the other parts of
the space station and dr. moon who is
back in this little home base has made a
discovery yeah they also mentioned
earlier in another cutscene that there
were low on rations because they were
stocked with them but like 90% of the
rations were rotting Hey so things are
things are happening here and it's all
windy out here yeah hey good thing he's
got protection he's strapped so again
you were sucked through a wormhole
your space station was sucked through a
wormhole we crash on into here the other
side that normal and no one knows where
this year's this planet is
you see what I so things are definitely
building out this is this is good was a
nice break after all of that too
mmm-hmm so did he make the statement
what's that has he made the three the
second statement second sting I'm not
sure we mean rashes knowing rot but the
honey is still good because honey so
basically what dr. moon has come up with
is a theory that for every second
I wasn't sure it's a theory they spend
on this planet it's 30 years 30 years
well back in yes galaxy Wow every second
so this has a very it has a very um
interstellar vibe to it yeah I'm kind of
getting that well it's not looking too
hot but this is actually good yeah not
looking good for both these astronauts
and your character who's looking for
these two time to repair a shuttle and
that means we can all get out of here
together
so as long as nothing else goes from it
also doesn't help Oh bathroom yo-ho-ho
oh look look the windows cracked right
here hmm okay storms wreaking havoc with
the cons oh okay
it was just a storm window go but you
have to wonder is it the storm yeah what
was it real or a rock okay I mean are
you okay with what I said before
Oh
because in the last cutscene we saw they
were singing to each other and now yeah
now it's are these the same people let's
ease at the end of the cutscene I think
so once oh boy you never know these
cutscenes run long yeah that's it I'm
back alright ladies and gentlemen I want
to thank you for joining us on Planet
whatever this is um thanks for coming in
and watching my thanks to Ritchie you
did a killer job on it I feel like you
only you only died like once or twice
really do a little more than that but it
was pretty good overall I didn't dice as
much as you know I die a lot so my
promise to Ritchie for coming out here
and playing being a good sport and thank
you guys for some awesome comments thank
you to the chat
I believe our written review is going to
be up very soon if not up already I'm
not quite sure so keep an eye out on
gamespot comm for that and if you guys
want to see the unboxing of this game
with the aim controller check out
YouTube that's up under game tech and
for any game play and all your other
gaming needs be sure to hit that
subscribe button on YouTube and that
follow button on Twitch so thank you
guys for joining us for a far point from
psvr
and we'll see you guys next time on
GameSpot see ya see ya
you
you